Sam can you settle this for us who do
you play this week we play wot we play a
Washington State on Friday okay that's
all we needed to talk to you about Sam
thank you we what classes you got today
I got a comm class a higher-level
communication class where we talk about
the global networks of sport and then
another level comm class where it's also
sport related but it's more I mean
recently we talked about kind of
politics and what's going on there and
we like to handle current events in
sport and talk about all that kind of
stuff so fun day for classes for me
today and I'm excited what do you are
you guys talking about Colin Kapernick
situation president Trump's tweets the
national anthem is that brought up in
class yeah yeah it's brought up in class
we just like to have you know educated
conversations about it because people
like myself and many other people in the
class might not be super well-educated
on what's going on why exactly people
are doing what they're doing so it's
always good to gain knowledge whenever
you don't know exactly what's going on
in a very very important situation I
guess in sports right now but I know
that you're coach clay Helton talked
about that you guys if you guys decide
to do something prior to this game with
Washington State well take me in the
locker room what's the conversation like
on if players would like to show unity
or protest or have some kind of display
yeah obviously we don't talk about it
much at all to be honest with you and
I'm being completely honest as well we
don't we don't really like to talk about
that kind of stuff if it is talked about
it all it always ends in a friendly
gesture and we end up kind of joking
around with it but it's it's definitely
serious so it's a serious situation but
we like to keep things really friendly
in our locker room and you know you'll
find us joking around more than us
talking about politics he's Sam Donald
and we just found out that they have
Washington state coming up on Friday
yeah I was also wondering tell me if
this story's true what was there a
chance you were going to be recruited to
play linebacker at USC and not
quarterback you know I was played
linebacker sophomore year and some
people came and looked at me as a
linebacker but I wasn't I was never
really recruited specifically to play
linebacker okay I'm very seriously it
also that's not necessarily true but
people did come and look at me just as
you know a receiver and a linebacker
could you play both ways could you play
linebacker maybe one play though
wouldn't it be nice Sam before you leave
USC just say could I go over there and
hit somebody maybe one play maybe I'm
like a Hail Mary or something but when
when the games ending or maybe when the
other team or you know maybe if the
other team is taken in me or some yeah
that's probably best for your future in
the NFL let them finish it you know but
if they're taking a knee then they might
be leading and then that's not a good
scenario either for you or you know we
might might be going into halftime they
might just be okay might just be killing
it to get into halftime so that's one
way of looking at it what do you see
what do you read what do you hear when
it's about you and it's hard to tune
that out and I'm sure your parents are
reading and hearing it but but what what
are you hear what do you see what do you
read I don't really look for stuff
usually and usually the stuff that I
read or watch is is you know a good
thing because people send it to me
they'll send it to me because they want
me to listen to it or hear it or watch
it so usually it's a good thing because
if people are sending it to me because
I'm not I'm not really the guy to look
myself up and see what's going on so I
guess I guess everything I watch is good
but at the same time I'm also aware of
you know my flaws with the quarterback
and where I need to get better but would
you learn more if they if they sent you
things that did deal with what you're
doing wrong or how would you process
that no I don't think I would
necessarily learn more because I know
where I need to get better and my
coaches know where I need to get better
and we work on that you know inside our
facilities so I mean I guess you know
people some people in the media can be
right of where I need to get better and
obviously I've done too many
interceptions this year and I'm aware of
that so and I know you know what it is I
need to fix and if I can if I can fix
that and my coaches that really helped
me out this week then I think I'll be I
think I'll be all right
what's different about this year's
opposed to last year but you personally
yeah the expectation that was pretty
heavy there soon yeah you know there's
there's a lot of expectations obvious to
any of that coming in so lot of
expectations but that doesn't change the
way I play you know I'm still gonna be
I'm still gonna be trying to you know
footballs in if I can but obviously you
got to be a little bit more careful but
I'm still gonna be the same player and
you know that's that's what's gotten us
here so far and I think if I try to
change things now it'd only be
detrimental to the team so as long as we
keep winning games I'm gonna be happy
with my choice so obviously you know I
need to need to play a little bit better
but you know just if we keep winning I'm
gonna be happy and I think that's and me
and coach clay talked about it a little
bit yesterday just you know the sign of
a good quarterback is if his team's
winning and that's really the end of it
and that's how I look at it as well tell
me about the Will Farrell meeting yeah
he's a great guy it was it was
interesting because we came in to we
came to the locker room after the game
and everyone was super excited and
you know everybody even the coaches were
just so starstruck with with Will Ferrel
but it was really interesting because on
the flip side Will Ferrell was a little
bit starstruck that he was with the USC
football team so there was kind of an
interesting dynamic there and then coach
clay had his words that he said to the
team and then he had Will Ferrell break
us down and he was like a like we have a
special guest Will Ferrell come in and
break us down and everyone thought he
was gonna crack a joke or at least I did
and he was just like hey guys you know
great win I like what I like what I'm
seeing out there and ball and he was
just a family on three one two three and
we also family so it was very
straightforward and I think it was cool
because you know he got to be part of
the team for a little bit and all the
players got to meet a great comedian and
Will Ferrell it's your favorite movie
from him I mean his little appearance
and wedding crashers is pretty good but
you know I think old school old school
is good he came into our studio and he
had those shoes on that he was when he's
jogging in the quad he's naked and he
and so he was wearing this shoot because
I said I'd love to have those shoes in
my man cave he wore those shoes in and
they wouldn't give him up and that
that's the only thing he had on that
night when he was running I thought that
was it was pretty cool to see these
green adidas that he had but and he's
such a great sports fan but but such a
really cool guy but I mean you can't go
wrong in all the movies that they that
you're saying there anybody else that
you've met a couple weeks ago country
singer and the country singer yeah he's
a really good guy
I think with and I also talked to Justin
Turner a little bit I think the common
denominator with all these people that
are meeting is they're all just they're
all so cool they're all just normal
people and I think that's
the coolest thing about meeting all
these different personalities and just
all these different famous athletes or
actors or singer-songwriters is that
they're just all of them seem to be such
cool guys and normal normal guys so you
know it's it's nice - it's nice to see
that an experienced up Sam hunt may have
bigger arms than you though now he for
sure does
he's a big dude he's like six six thirty
six more I was also surprised when I saw
Will Ferrell because he was super tall
but um yeah yeah no I think I think Sam
hunt got me there on the on the bicep
curls
oh yeah but did he play college football
what do you a quarterback yeah yeah he
actually our quarterback coach Tyson
Hilton coached him University of Alabama
Birmingham yeah yeah so there's that
little connection there but no it's it's
really cool to hear stories from you
know times where they would just tell
Sam - hey go entertain the team for a
little bit while the Walter coaches are
in the staff meeting because he's such
an entertainer but yeah there's there's
great stories about Sam about Sam hunt
and it's cool to just hear those stories
I guess I'll leave you with this why do
we assume that this is your last year
UNC I'm not sure it's uh you know I'm a
redshirt sophomore and I'm eligible for
the job after this year and I had a
pretty good year last year so I think
that's probably a reason give me the
reason you come back I'm not really sure
honestly right now I think I'll handle
that when the time comes but right now
I'm just really focused on the season
and trying to improve my game you know
every single every single day because
you know obviously I'm not a finished
product and I'd like to get better as
the season progresses so I think that's
just my only worry right now you know
see the answer would have been because I
missed the camaraderie that
college experience and like you can get
around this question just in the future
Sam and you know you you know that's all
you just say I love the college
experience I love coach helped and I
don't want you know going back to my
teammates and if we don't win a national
title to go back and then fight on
that's then that's all you have say okay
right on your good then you just say
fight on and then that's it yeah I'll
use that in the future yeah I'll help
you there all right hey good luck in
class and glad you're going and thanks
for joining us I appreciate that so Sam
Darnell the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience